Over the years, Disney and Pixar have created
movies based around a variety of lovable creatures,
from princesses and frogs, to video game characters,
to children's toys come to life when their
owners aren't looking.
For their newest release, Pixar has tapped
into a character who previously played the
sidekick to a clown fish on the hunt for his
missing son.
But, there are plenty of other characters
from Disney and Pixar with their own story
to tell, just like Finding Dory.
Here are 10 Disney and Pixar sidekicks who
deserve their own movie.
Bing Bong
There was plenty to laugh and cry at in Pixar's
Inside Out, and one character who managed
to cause both reactions in audience members
was Riley's imaginary friend Bing Bong.
The character has everything needed for a
Pixar movie of his own: a theme song, an eccentric
personality, and a heartbreaking story.
Though Inside Out doesn't leave room for a
sequel following Bing Bong, the imaginary
part-cat, part-elephant, part-dolphin creature
could certainly lead a prequel film about
his time with Riley, and how their relationship
changed as she got older.
Mushu & Cri-Kee
One of two companions to Mulan in the Disney
movie surrounding her decision to join the
army in her father's place, Mushu and the
lucky cricket are the comedic relief to the
heroine.
The Timon and Pumbaa to The Lion King's Simba,
of sorts.
But, unlike Timon and Pumbaa who received
their own movie in The Lion King 1 1/2, Mushu
and Cri-Kee haven't starred in their own Disney
spinoff.
However, the characters are a perfect focus
for a spinoff.
Whether they go on their own mission to save
China or act as the Fa family's guardians
with another member of the house, Mushu and
Cri-Kee deserve their own Disney movie.
Edna Mode
Although Frozone - or any number of fellow
superheroes from The Incredibles - would easily
be able to sustain his own movie, Edna Mode
could provide a departure from the typical
superhero story.
Instead, a movie following the fashion designer
could focus on her unique side of the superhero
world, as the person in charge of creating
and mending the heroes' super-suits.
With her demanding nature, her talent for
working with special fabrics, and perhaps
some other hidden skills that weren't on display
in The Incredibles, Edna could be the lead
in her own adventure.
Roz
When first introduced in Monsters, Inc., Roz
seems to be a straightforward character: a
grouchy, no-nonsense worker to Mike and Sully's
more complicated antics.
So, when Roz is revealed to be an undercover
agent with the Child Detection Agency, viewers
are taken by surprise in the abrupt turnaround
from boring coworker to mysterious secret
agent.
Considering Roz spent years undercover, and
previously worked for the CDA prior to that
mission, there is still plenty that Pixar
fans don't know about this particular monster
- and plenty of ground to cover in an entire
movie dedicated to Roz.
Baymax
The healthcare robot devoted to making sure
Hiro Hamada was safe and healthy quickly became
a scene-stealer in Disney's Big Hero 6.
Between Baymax having trouble understanding
the complexities of humans and his silly disposition
when his battery is depleted, the character
easily became a favorite among fans young
and old.
Plus, though he begins the film as Hiro's
healthcare companion, Baymax becomes a hero
in his own right.
So, a Baymax-centric movie would a be perfect
sequel or spinoff from Big Hero 6 - Disney
just needs to come up with a reason for Baymax
to go on a solo mission.
Little Green Men
There are plenty of different characters from
Pixar's three Toy Story movies who deserve
their own films - like Bonnie's toys Buttercup,
Peas-in-a-pod, and Mr. Pricklepants.
But, some of the more mysterious characters
who have shared the screen with Woody and
Buzz are the Little Green Men that the toys
meet at Pizza Planet.
Other than their devotion to their claw god,
we don't know much about these green aliens.
Given how Illumination's Minions have taken
over pop culture, the world may be ready for
a movie all about Toy Story's Little Green
Men.
Cogsworth & Lumière
Before Belle stepped into the Beast's castle
and began to unravel the magic spell that
had been placed on the prince, those who populated
the fortress were busy leading their own enchanted
lives.
From Cogsworth and Lumière to other members
of the household like Mrs. Potts, Chip, and
the Wardrobe, the prince's castle was full
of ordinary people stuck in an extraordinary
world.
So, what was life like in the castle before
Belle arrived, or before the enchantress cast
the spell on the prince and everyone else
in the household?
Cogsworth and Lumière, with their charming
banter, could certainly sustain an entertaining
prequel all their own as they navigate the
Beast's household prior to Belle's arrival.
Scuttle
Before Marlin, Nemo, and Dory led audiences
on a new adventure through the big blue sea,
Ariel, Sebastian, and Flounder were the go-to
ocean experts in The Little Mermaid.
But, when it came to knowledge of the land,
they turned to Scuttle the seagull, whose
expertise of human objects is unparalleled
- in it's ridiculousness of course.
The eccentric bird, with his penchant for
coming up with unique names like dinglehopper
and snarfblatt, would be a fun guide through
the human world in his own movie, perhaps
on his own quest to find a particularly intriguing
object - like a spork.
Russell & Dug
After the first 10 minutes or so of Up effectively
leaves everyone in the audience heartbroken,
the movie proceeds to build viewers back up
through Carl's continued adventure after the
death of his wife and co-adventurer Ellie.
Along the way, Carl meeds Wilderness Explorer
Russell and a dog with the ability to speak
named Dug.
Though Up seems to bring Carl's story to a
close, Russell and Dug are only at the beginning
of their adventuring days.
What other Wilderness Explorer badges does
Russell earn?
Does Dug ever catch a squirrel?
These questions could be answered in a Pixar
movie completely devoted to these sidekicks
turned adventurerers.
Olaf
An enthusiastic snowman with a love of summertime
and warm hugs, the character of Olaf easily
won over the hearts of viewers in Disney's
Frozen.
The friendliest snowman in Arendelle was created
by Elsa's magic as a friend for Anna, and
helps the younger princess rescue her sister
from herself as well as the villainous Hans.
Though Frozen ends with Arendelle's magically-induced
winter coming to an end and Elsa creating
a snowcloud to keep Olaf solid, there's still
more story to tell with this happy snowman.
Perhaps he follows in Dory's footsteps and
goes on a journey to find a family.
There are many sidekicks in the history of
Disney animation who deserve their own movie,
so did we miss any of your favorites?
Let us know in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one!